good morning believe nation today's
message is stand up to yourself over to
you Les Brown overcoming the negative
conversation that a no dialogue is going
on all the time all the time
even when you don't want it to be there
you can't stop yourself right now from
thinking you can't do it it's going on
and so learning how to empower yourself
part of doing that is standing up to
yourself you've got to stand up inside
yourself sometimes and say shut up
you've got to do this I was going to
give a presentation and this voice
inside of me saying you can't do this
you don't have everything it takes us
shut up I'm behind on my bills and you
telling me what I can't do I have got to
do it
you get scared sometimes your mind will
go blink on you
some people will you will allow to
unnerve you and you wonder what's wrong
with me I'm not crazy that's why you've
got to learn to make a conscious
deliberate determined effort to stand up
inside yourself working on yourself
watching that inner dialogue it will
determine the quality of your life this
is a really important message because we
all have limiting personal beliefs we
all hold ourselves back we all have this
story that we tell ourselves we tell
ourselves that and the only way you're
gonna break free of those limiting
personal beliefs is to stand up to
yourself to understand that these are
just stories that you're telling
yourselves that none of them are
actually true and if you can change that
mindset to help you understand that you
have the ability to make changes for
yourself you have the ability to control
your own life and your path and your
journey then it frees you so stand up
for yourself and go build the company of
your dreams
so my question the day today is what do
you need to stand up to yourself for
leave in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso